A key takeaway from life cycles is that
your application runs until Android
needs to free resources or
something else.
That means, it's best if we design
Sunshine to continue to work well even
if the operating system has to close us
and the app no longer has weather data.
One might ask, this is the error
of the connected cloud.
Why don't we just always
fetch the weather on demand?
Do we really need to worry about
saving anything on the device?
Well, first,
user experience is important.
When Sunshine is launched, we want our
users to be immediately greeted with up
to date hot off the API weather
information and not a blank screen.
The faster people can use an app,
the more it will be used.
For something like weather, people want
the details immediately available.
Second, using any radio is detrimental
to the battery life of the device,
especially the cellular radio.
Storing the weather data rather
than fetching it each time saves
battery life.
And that leads to happier users.
Third, there are many users
on metered data plans or
users may be roaming when
they want to use Sunshine.
All those unnecessary
data fetches can add up.
Fourth, if you're running a web
service for your application,
you'll be highly motivated to reduce
the server load and network bandwidth.
Fifth, there are still
lots of places that don't
have a network connection
available constantly.
One of the prime advantages of having a
mobile app is being resistant to bad or
non-existent network conditions.
Sixth, and finally, you never know
where a user will want to use your app.
Although our weather API currently
doesn't support outer space locations.
Being smart about the way we use system
resources is key to making the Sunshine
a good Android citizen.
As conscientious developers, we strive
to make all of our apps adhere to these
principles by minimizing
network activity and
working seamlessly between offline and
online states.
We persist data in Sunshine to make
it both a better experience for
users, while making it use less
network and battery resources.